the jurogan experience you know the
jeffrey epstein thinks a weird
comparison because
eric weinstein says jeffrey abstinene
wasn't smooth at all
i i know that's what eric says eric is
so much
far smarter than the average human being
far smarter to the point where
he's not buying anybody's [ __ ] and
he met with epstein and he said right
away he's like well this is a construct
he's like he's an actor this is a
construct this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about
he thought it was 100 [ __ ] i love
eric
but uh and he is indeed brilliant uh
probably way smarter than me
but he's also flawed no
like all humans are what and i do i
disagree with him on that one
well listen did you meet jeffrey
absolutely no but i've met a lot of
people
who did you meet the madam uh well
just the mit so all the scientists all
like everybody met him this is the dark
thing
all the scientists met him let me help
you out here yeah here's the difference
here's one of the differences first of
all eric
has gotten laid yeah it's happened
before
yes he probably got laid a lot when he
was younger just to clarify smooth
talkers i have also gotten laid
congratulations referring to now i'm not
talking about you i'm talking about a
lot of these scientists
a lot of these scientists that is their
kryptonite
it's not a coincidence that this guy
allegedly it's not a coincidence this
guy allegedly
involved a huge part of the scientific
community
in this crazy thing where he's got a
[ __ ] island
and he ships off these brilliant minds
over there allegedly
and introduces them to a lot of these
ladies allegedly okay
listen that is the kryptonite i meant
allegedly referring to the kryptonite
of sex being a kryptonite for scientists
for dorks
for dorks yes that will always disagree
on this but yeah
there's agree uh there's no disagreeing
i don't think that
we can put all scientists in the group
of dorks but yes there's
a lot of dark in there that's why i saw
through the [ __ ]
i don't know listen that's that's
literally what you're saying that's
conspiratorial i think because to say
there's many elements i think i think
what eric says which is like
he was just uh a tool of something
bigger
is that's a problem to me because it
removes
the responsibility of evil from an
individual
and saying that there's some other evil
be beside in in the darkness
it's it's possible no no no no no no no
he's saying that he's a part of the
intelligence community
and that's that's actually been reported
on do you know that when he was arrested
the initial
arrest and when he was given a very
lenient sentence one of the
guys who was involved in that case said
it was above my pay grade
and that i was told he was a part of the
intelligence community
now the word had always been that he was
either a mossad agent or someone along
those lines now
if you have some of the most brilliant
minds in the world and you want to
compromise
them and you want to and somehow or
another get them entangled
in your world there's two great steps i
think you need some more of that
i was going to say but you want to be
hold up i thought you consider yourself
a man you're drinking
we're talking about not sufficient are
you drinking it not finished i know i
finished mine before you [ __ ] we should
have another one
okay
what i was saying is if you wanted to
compromise cheers sir
cheers good to see you man good to see
you legitimately really always
really good to see you here as i try to
talk you to moving to texas
um there's two two ways you would
compromise the scientific community
one of them being money right so he
gives them money funding that helps them
millions of dollars right donated
millions of dollars to
various uh projects various things
you're working on to
women bring all these scientists
together
bring these brilliant guys together with
the promise of
money for all their projects they're
working on and then you
bring them to an island and they say hey
everything's fine here
don't worry about it you know i got a
[ __ ] temple that's painted like the
jewish flag
he's really flagged i have faith that
scientists have more integrity than that
but
but it's not a matter of integrity like
everything was above board
if they don't know what he's doing and
they're innocent
right then they haven't done anything
wrong and he's giving them money and
taking pictures with them
just simply by taking pictures with them
they're they're oh they're compromised
you're saying yeah i see
okay i thought you meant like like say
there was a beautiful young lady here
and then she was tasked with uh
escorting me around to show how
wonderful texts all you have to do
is have photographs with you and this
beautiful young
compromise yes now i do not know
what happened obviously because i wasn't
there but i would imagine
that if he was really a part of the
intelligence community
there was probably a directive there was
probably something that they were
working on to try to
get these people to go along with
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing but see
to me that those are both
different flavors of evil both of them
are not good
but okay so but the intelligence
community has always done that
they have always compromised people with
sex and they've always compromised
people with money
is that this is a standard you know i've
directly talked to people who are in the
cia
who would describe methods that they
would use to compromise individuals
wait so is this could the scientists
have done something to avoid it
it's hard because if they don't know
right they're they're promised funding
and then you have other scientists that
are also going to be there hey
this guy's going to be there hey you got
that guy this guy won
you know this prize and he's going to be
there and this guy's from mit
he's going to be there and you're like
well that'll be a fun party yeah you
know let's go
should i bring my wife if epstein is
that
like why so there was i guess actually
eric makes this argument is like the
whole thing that
uh jeffrey epstein was a pedophile
was actually a negative in that sense
for the if he is
a part of like the intelligence
community you know what i think he
that the fact that he's a criminal sorry
in fact
i interrupted you um i think it is a
negative but i think
when you're involved in that much
depravity
i think you can get compromised i think
it's like a dea h and it becomes a drug
dealer
you know i think when you're around
darkness
all the time i mean that happens a lot
where undercover cops become drug
dealers
just happens they they live in that
world for too long and it just gets in
their veins
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience